frente al tema de las elecciones
esperaría que fueran incluso mucho antes
de la fecha anunciada por la presidenta
boluarte qué tan pertinentes son estos
plazos
es muy complicado que sea antes porque
se requiere organizar el proceso
electoral y la la idea de que fuera en
abril de 2023 como es como lo establece
un proyecto que está en la comisión de
constitución del Congreso es muy
improbable lo lo más viable es que se
han se realicen elecciones Y es que se
aprueba el proyecto que va a presentar
la presidenta es que sea el 2024 ahora
cuál puede ser el destino de boluarte
durante estos 15 meses antes de las
elecciones
bueno todo depende de cómo se
desarrollen los acontecimientos y Y eso
tuvo un mal inicio el El golpe de estado
El Siete de diciembre fue indiscutible
en el momento en que Castillo da el
mensaje disolviendo el congreso
disponiendo la reorganización del
Ministerio Público y del poder judicial
perdió el cargo y se convirtió en un
presidente de facto Sin embargo el
congreso para
recuperar protagonismo organizó un
ritual en el cual lo declaró vacante del
cargo a quien ya no era presidente esto
en realidad fue algo que no pasó de los
pintoresco Pero lo que sí fue complicado
fue que el día de ayer el congreso en en
un solo día
declaró que el presidente castillo de
podía ser progresado judicialmente que
esto es un proceso procedimiento que se
llama ante juicio que se activa con una
denuncia constitucional eso no se puede
hacer en un solo día en el artículo 89
del reglamento del Congreso dice que hay
una serie de actos que se deben cumplir
en por lo menos dos semanas y tan cierto
es eso que hoy día la fiscal de la
nación ha presentado la denuncia
constitucional a pesar de que el
congreso ha aprobado esta resolución que
habilita el procesamiento del del
expresidente Castillo la fiscal
conociendo que esto es
anticonstitucional ha presentado el
pedido recién entonces estas situaciones
Estas ideas y venidas este este afán de
protagonizar desde sacar provecho en la
para la elección que pueda sobrevenir
puede generar muchas complicaciones lo
mejor sería que que los políticos
advirtiendo el momento de emergencia que
vive el Perú depongan estas aspiraciones
y caminen hacia una transición
sosegada y y exenta devoluciones ahora
señor Jairo que se espera que pase con
la denuncia constitucional contra
Castillo va a prosperar
es muy probable que sí pero eso va a
tomar este una o dos semanas y después
de eso lo más probable es que se le
acuse por conspiración para rebelión
porque la rebelión es un es un acto que
requiere un alzamiento en armas y sin
embargo lo que se sospecha es que ha
habido no un alcemento en armas porque
esto fue
superado en menos de una hora y no se
utilizó no se utilizó armas pero el pero
el presidente Castillo supremo las
fuerzas armadas por lo tanto se sospecha
que hubo algún concierto con uno o más
personajes civiles o militares eso es
esclares era Y sí lo hubo se le se le
podrá condenar por rebelión insinúa nada
de eso se le se le absolverá